okay play me so here we go choose my age
20
really is six no I don't know what to do
he's out of book haha
not g6 at eater shows a profound
understanding or a profound lack of
understanding just go and go and attack
his knights
he's playing really slowly
no we're going to change my plan
I'm sorry to say that minus 20 is really
playing horribly strategically right now
but you might get win the game
you
this is probably going to go down in
history as one of the best chess games
ever played castles that's such a risky
move now I'm going to play King F in one
the subtle point is now that I
threatened ninety four and then if it
takes the pawn on e5 I can go Bishop f4
and you won't have the check on f3 this
should be so as such a pointless and
stupid move
if I don't win this game I'm never going
to play -20 again
are you kidding me
he's trying to lose rookie one
extraordinary subtle
Bishop a6 completely pointless okay it's
time to kill him
so I thought he might sacrifice his
queen but this position is still lost
okay now I'm getting nagging feeling
that I'm gonna blunder this all the way
I don't know how
how am i chick meeting him now I'm going
to go for the primitive idiot way g6 are
you serious
you
okay let's try to attack with brute
force
ah tricky tricky tricky tricky
now is threatening to take on f2 we
check and then I cannot take back
because then my queen will be lost
think I should still be winning but now
I'm really starting to screw up or maybe
not
oh yeah I think I should be checked
Medicare I'm just not seeing quite how
if we go Queen h4 it's going to take on
g5 and have some resources yet
okay let's try s3 this looks pretty good
take sent you five I'm just going to
take that one back
take the night now I cannot possibly see
how we can define this king I'm
threatening his rook and threatening
checkmate in a few moves
you can go route b7 now which I missed
rook b8 that's really ice cold
so now here she is threatening checkmate
in two moves check check
I'm messing up so bad
okay let me try and play for when varial
backfire though I think he cannot take
the poem now but unless I might be wrong
simply Bishop f5
route b6 he has no shame no shame
whatsoever
so if I go queen of four I'm blundering
my Knights take this poem
I take a Sunday - is threatening mate
I put the pace on the wrong square just
under this hole
I didn't intend to go to 8 e 7
yeah yeah stop thinking wherever you go
it's perpetual check I screwed up you're
going to draw ha ha that's an
interesting attempt you didn't earn any
points okay so I outplayed him in the
opening then won the Queen he fought
well I screwed up it was a draw life
goes on